in the lobby of Ramsay Solutions Eddie
and Suzie are with us hey guys how are
ya good
welcome welcome where are you from we're
from Monument Colorado which is just
north of Colorado Springs absolutely
cool well welcome to Nashville thank you
for having us and you're here to do your
debt-free scream we are how much have
you paid off
we paid off a hundred and seventy five
thousand dollars over the course of
about seven years that is awesome and
your range of income through that but
time we started at about eighty and then
we went down to about sixty Eddie got
laid off for a little while and this
year we're gonna be pushing 180 Wow nice
increases yeah so what do you guys do
for a living I'm a software engineer and
I'm a project manager very good good for
you guys well done so I'm guessing with
the length of time seven years that this
is your mortgage and everything no it's
not yeah big student loan debt okay one
hundred and twenty thousand dollars
worth of student loan debt at fifty five
thousand and other huh yeah what was the
rest of it cars credit card that's it
you were just like normal just normal
but just a big pile of it huh yes I wish
someone had warned us of the dangers of
student loans yeah yeah so um Wow
what started this process seven years
ago I got pregnant with our oldest
Charlie he's six now mm-hmm
so I mean when you have a new little one
incoming that is a big motivator and
then so we were motivated to get our
debt paid off then but then about two
weeks when I was ready to go back from
maternity leave with Charlie mm-hmm
Eddie comes home and tells me he's been
laid off Wow so talk about scary you
know a lot of pressure new parents yeah
and this pile of mountain of debt facing
you yeah yeah but you can't knock out
because we got no income coming yep Wow
and how long did it take to get squared
around after that luckily I ended up in
a better job and it was only about uh
about a month oh that's good
yeah I wasn't too much of a setback then
no but emotionally it underscored the
reason that you were doing this yeah
baby scary then but it worked out it was
a blessing in disguise because that
meant that Charlie got to spend more
time with Daddy before he went to work
and it made it easier for me to go back
to work okay all right Wow very cool now
how long has these this income shot back
shot way up how long have you had the
big income only about the last four
years we paid off about 125 of that in
the last four years okay in the last
four years we were over 120 put it that
way
okay yeah all right well good for you
why did it go you guys so what do you
tell people the key to getting out of
debt is I would say having a plan and
sticking to the budget I mean if you
don't have have a plan then your money
just kind of trickles through fingers
and don't know where it goes mm-hmm
what was the worst thing you guys did
while you're trying this that messed you
up the most that kept you from doing it
faster I would say when we fell off the
wagon yeah long story short we were out
on a date and we were working the
program we were making great progress
and had a little bit of time between
dinner and the movie and we're like you
know what we've been talking about
getting a bigger vehicle so let's just
go to car max and look around because
there's no pressure and we'll just kind
of see what we want and we ended up
buying a vehicle that night oh yeah
$30,000 impulsed a car yeah so the next
morning we're like oh my god what do we
do but I think the important thing is is
we got back up even though we fell off
the wagon we got back up and we pressed
on and we got it all paid off Wow we
drove it here on the trip well we got to
have some part of the story that's good
oh my gosh well congratulations you guys
how's it feel to be debt-free it's just
amazing it's awesome it's amazing I'm so
excited about everything that we can do
and save and give now because we are
blessed to have a great income and I'm
just excited about what our future looks
like and what our kiddos future looks
like absolutely very cool so Charlie was
born
ago do you have other children yes Davey
is four okay so David and Charlie have
they been practicing all the way from
Colorado they're debt-free scream all
right very fun very cool all right let's
get them in here and get them lined up
and make them part of the plan
Eddy and Suzie and Charlie and David
from Colorado Springs area a hundred and
seventy-five thousand dollars paid off
in seven years making 80 to 60 to 180
count it down
let's hear a debt free scream alright
ready three two one good job you guys
that right there's how it's done I love
it I love it I love it very very well
done hey guys thanks for watching if you
enjoyed this video click the subscribe
button to get the latest content and
check out these other great clips from
the show you can do this you know that
really is a message whether you've got
two hundred seventy thousand dollars in
student loan debt or twenty seven
thousand well you've got a fifty
thousand dollar income on a $500,000 in
common
you